de france aujourd'hui avec gérard dalmaz
on va se rendre à l'île de ré où
apparemment tout est suspendu un puits
oui on pourrait dire d'ailleurs que
c'était l'arlésienne de ré ben ça ne
l'est plus parce que on disait ponts ou
pas mon meilleur à pont sur un pauvre on
en parle depuis 20 ans de ce fameux pont
de l'île de ré comme d'ailleurs c'était
le cas pour les ronds pour noirmoutier
il a été décidé en 74 par le conseil
général de la charente-maritime qui est
le département l'île de ré c'est un
canton l'île de ré 10 communes il a été
confirmé en 78 et puis très récemment
alors côté population peut se poser la
question comment réagit-elle bien au
début c'était très passionnel c'était
50-50 mais on peut dire que tout de même
ça penche du côté du pont si je puis
dire 60 40 environ
car on peut dire aussi ajouté enfin que
c'est un peu un combat d'arrière garde
le pont va se faire c'est un mal
nécessaire le calendrier sera à peu près
celui ci 84 85
début du chantier et on peut dire que 87
et bien la première voiture somme
passera le ph car c'est un péage bien
sûr il sera gratuit repéré un jour mais
en tout cas le pont donc sera sortie de
mer en 87 à peu près le bac
logeant hollandais origine du mot
apporte sa ration quotidienne
incessantes d'habitants de touristes à
l'île de ré 18 heures sur 24 le va et
vient des bourdons entre l'île à la
taille de guêpe et le port de la pallice
à la fois la contrainte le handicap de
lille mais sa chance son image
aussi ce n'est pas toujours
l'entousiasme pour le futur pont moi
j'ai bien connu il devrait comme ça je
ne dis pas ça serait puni
en revanche dans cette voiture bleue qui
fait l'aller retour quotidien 1re était
partisan ferme d'une liaison fixe avec
l'agglomération de la recherche alors un
nouveau système de bacs
faut-il aussi un tunnel non pour lui le
mieux c'est le pont à péage qui est
d'ailleurs décidé depuis 1974
le gong la solution rentable j'en veux
pour preuve que ce sont les ponts de
l'île d'oléron et de la seudre qui
actuellement paye le déficit de la
liaison par bach
je peux citer un chiffre pour mémoire je
crois que c'est un milliard deux cents
millions de centimes pour l'année 82
c'est énorme et ça va aller en
s'accroissant
ajoutons que ray ne peut plus vivre sur
elle même économiquement elle coule dix
mois sur douze
et puis il y a les problèmes d'attentes
de santé de sécurité pendant les
vacances les tempêtes
bref il faut entre l'île blanche veut
les verts et le continent
un trait continu
les débats qui marque plus de points
bien et a eu leur grève le pont
ouverture prévue 87 coûte au moins 50
milliards de centimes voici la maquette
a longtemps partagé les rétais mais le
débat est moins passionnelle depuis les
dernières grèves des bacs
pourtant le pont va bouleverser la vie
de ré l'île n'est absolument pas
préparés ni dans les textes ni surtout
dans les mentalités et à mon sens je
pense qu'il aurait fallu en premier lieu
s'assurer d'une protection efficace et
voir l'effet de la protection ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui vous voyez
sur cette carte le territoire de la
commune de la flotte du 130 hectares
mitée par environ 600 emplacements de
camping caravaning particulier ce
phénomène risque de s'intensifier ne
risquons d'avoir une véritable ville de
plein air dans tout l'environnement de
la commune de la flotte 12000 rétais
200000 vacanciers et ces chiffres
peuvent doubler avec le pont lille
deviendrait un radeau de pavillons de
caravanes avec une flambée des prix des
terrains et l'alourdissement du mitage
comptant déjà trois mille camping privé
on immobilise la caravane on creuse le
petit coin au fond du jardin
le puits et voilà un cabanon ça me
suffit face à ce risque de déformation
qui détruirait l'identité de lille il
faut des mesures strictes de protection
l'application des règlements existants
ou à venir peut-être un remembrement
général en tout cas une politique
agricole urgente dans son marais salants
écouter l'un des derniers pas luthier au
palais s'est emballé et tout le monde
faire ce qu'il veut je les ai pas
possible autrement dit il faudra
contrôler ce qui se passe une fois les
pour l'instant c'est fait maintenant
continuer ce qui se fait maintenant
voilà à voir les comme chez nous par
exemple eh bien on a fait un
remembrement on à la zone agricole
la zone touristique et c'est fini
alors automatiquement un jeune agricole
on peut même pas même le propriétaire
n'a pas droit de mettre une toile de
tente bientôt le bac ne sera plus qu'un
souvenir puisque rennes ne sera plus qu
une presqu'île
voici d'ailleurs l'opinion d'un vieux
rétais qui a été chargé de nombreux
mandats il connaît l'île par coeur il a
dans son coeur mais pol pot est probable
qu'il sera construit
s'il est probable parce que rien
n'arrête le programme même quand c'est
une erreur et oui effectivement monsieur
gérard daguise on peut remarquer que
malgré tout que les réactions sont je
dirais mi figue mi raisin
et c'est encore un peu confus mais il
faut dire aussi que ce serait un
changement irréversible et que je crois
que tout le monde on n'a pas conscience
sur place alors brièvement
actuellement il va y avoir une enquête
d'utilité publique bientôt une décision
d'utilité publique du moins en principe
était alors en même temps il se passe
une espèce d'études ou sein des dix
communes sur une charte des décisions à
prendre en matière de protection car il
faut par exemple prendre un petit coup
d'oeil à dun se donner un petit coup
d'oeil un petit peu critique du côté des
lotissements qui ont fleuri du côté de
marmoutier et ça n'est pas le seul
exemple je crois que demain on se rend
dans une autre il met ses pas et vous
savez quoi je regarde dans l'île de de
saint gérard lorsque vous êtes rendu
dans l'île de ré ce que j'ai eu le temps
d'aller au marché car de course non j'ai
peu de temps parce qu'on a travaillé
très vite et dont vous n'avez ribéry
pleuvait beaucoup mais il attend
regarder le dj voletant parce que je
peux vous dire c'est que l'île de ré
réputé pour ses asperges et ses pommes
de terre primeur